je vous propose de faire ensemble un
voyage un voyage rapide mais lointain un
voyage dans le futur
allons sur mars la planète rouge
nous sommes en 2050 nous avons parcouru
500 millions de kilomètres nous sommes
confortablement installé dans un village
martien 500 millions de kilomètres c'est
environ 4 fois la distance entre la
terre et le soleil
quand un terrien nous envoie un message
nous devons attendre dix minutes pour
qu'ils nous parviennent c'est pas facile
de communiquer la gravité et de 3,8 g
nous faisons donc environ 40% de notre
poids sur terre c'est particulier mais
plutôt amusant mais il y a moins
agréable l'atmosphère est peu attractive
la pression est de 6 milliards soit une
atmosphère d'environ 150 fois moins
dense que sur terre mais surtout sa
composition avec 96 % de co2 le gaz
carbonique et pas respirable du tout
alors il vaut mieux avoir être bien
couvert et avoir son générateur
d'oxygène pour faire du jardin
rien n'est simple le soleil beaucoup
plus lointains ne nous apportent que 35
à 50% de l'énergie reçue sur terre
la température il varie donc entre -3 à
-132 gré - 130 degrés même les canadiens
ils trouvent ça froid les vents les
tempêtes de poussière sont permanents
le rayonnement solaire les rayons
cosmiques ne sont arrêtés ni par
l'atmosphère ni par le champ magnétique
absent alors un conseil sortez pas de
cette salle néanmoins
aujourd'hui mars est devenu la banlieue
de la terre
et si nous pouvons aujourd'hui passer
quelques temps en toute sécurité et
confort sur cette planète
c'est grâce à des missions pionnière qui
ont fait progresser à pas de géant
notre connaissance sur cette planète
rappelez vous c'était le 14 mars 2016
une mission spatiale nommé exomars
débutait par le lancement d'une fusée
proton depuis baïkonour au kazakhstan
objectif conquérir ce nouvel horizon et
y poser la première sonde européenne
nommée schiaparelli ce jour là la
tension était maximale pour les
ingénieurs et les scientifiques du
projet il avait l'ambition d'innover
d'être ce qu'ils allaient faire
progresser notre connaissance
leur rêve depuis 10 15 ans de poser leur
bébé si loin après tant d'efforts
devenait réalité des années de travail
des mois de vérifications des semaines
de préparation au kazakhstan puis le
décollage
la longue attente ou être mise sur la
bonne route
la réception des signaux de ce
nouveau-né de l'espace qui nous
indiquait sa bonne santé
des moments forts en émotions on
cherchait alors s'il y avait des traces
de vie sur mars avec ses instruments
scientifiques notre satellite renifleurs
allait analyser l'atmosphère de mars
la question centrale de la présence de
méthane sur mars
allez trouver sa réponse le méthane est
un indicateur de vie biologique
potentiel un détecteur de neutrons aller
nous indiquer si et où de l'eau se
trouvait dans le sol de mars d image
stéréo aller nous fournir plus de
détails sur le paysage de mars
mais surtout cette mission allait
préparer l'arrivée d'un véhicule mobile
un rover qui a quitté la terre en 2018
il ya fort longtemps mars et la terre
était semblable avec d'immenses océan
liquide à leur surface l'environnement
et les processus chimiques étaient
semblables comme sur deux planètes
jumelles puis mars fut l'objet d'un
terrible changement climatique
il y à 3 5 milliards d'années
à partir de ce moment-là mars est devenu
aride stérile froides à hostile
à sa surface en tout cas les
rayonnements solaires et l'atmosphère
ténue interdisait toute forme de vie à
la surface les rayonnements cosmiques ou
haché menu les éventuels molécules
organiques
mais qu'en est-il en profondeur à l'abri
de ces agressions une nouvelle mission
allait percer ce secret mais se poser
sur mars était alors périlleux entrée
dans l'atmosphère à 21 milles kilomètres
heure et à 120 km d'altitude
le bouclier thermique atteint 1500
degrés les parachute s'ouvre à 1700 km
heure et freine la sonde à 250
kilomètres heure à environ 1 km
d'altitude puis les rétrofusées termine
la descente qui n'aura pas duré plus de
six minutes
ensuite notre véhicule se déploie
puis il va entamer son périple sur le
sol de mars
ce véhicule est muni d'une perceuse
capable d'atteindre 2 mètres de
profondeur grâce à son laboratoire
embarqué il va analyser les roches et
les sédiments extraits et nous allions
enfin pour la première fois avoir une
réponse à cette question fondamentale
la vie est-elle ou at elle été présente
ailleurs que sur terre
alors quel regard souvent nous porter
sur notre terre en 2050 la conquête de
mars a été un immense défi pour les
scientifiques et les ingénieurs
l'analyse de l'atmosphère de mars nous a
permis de progresser dans notre
compréhension des phénomènes et du
climat sur terre la conquête de mars
nous a permis de progresser dans nos
techniques de gestion et de traitement
de l'eau de retraitement des déchets
mais surtout l'esprit de conquête et
d'exploration partagé par tous les
acteurs a permis de contribuer à un
monde plus fraternel plus solidaire et
donc plus pacifique
au fait faites attention ne vous perdez
pas parce que vous avez peut-être déjà
vu que si vous restez seul sur mars
la situation va être délicate à gérer
alors après ce court séjour martien je
vous propose de rentrer sur terre en
france à cannes fin avril 2016
les